merry christmas you know merry christmas
you know damn just get out there and
just damn tell somebody
merry christmas damn it
damn
just if you got a damn ring somebody's
neck
if they don't get it
give it to them
merry christmas
you tell them it's that time of year
get a nice gift for someone
you know get somebody something they can
use if you have a maybe you got a buddy
who's never been to the beach
get him give him a little bucket of sand
or something give his wife a half bucket
maybe uh
maybe somebody don't have a legs or
something you know
get them um
draw some draw a picture of them with
legs
and say hey man that's how i see you
you know i see you complete
you know do something we had a
you know if somebody doesn't have a
tongue we had a fellow didn't have a
tongue bust and somebody wrote down all
the flavors on a piece of
uh poster board
so he could point at him when he was
enjoying something
look it's tart look it's you know fruit
based or whatever
oh [__] this has lead in it and he
pointed lead
you know help somebody out
you know just be a stand for decency if
you can this time of year
you have a buddy that that um
that's never been outdoors get him a
tree get him a little tree bring it
inside
get him a little you know
get him a bird call or something hide
behind the tree say hey this is what
it's like
if you want to ven if you ever want to
do you want to be brave
you know we had a
a cousin that couldn't read
and um
and somebody got him a damn book and
that's not good
you know because that's really
get them a letter draw a big letter on
the thing say hey this is it l
m
r
you know don't
you don't want to ruin somebody's day
either
you know somebody can't you know i
remember he couldn't read they gave him
a book and everybody's like
you know because he can't
you know you can't put a toddler on
mount everest
you got to put him on an ant hill first
[Music]
there you go and that is the first knoll
uh
and i look i like my mute i want my my
christmas i don't care if the house
burns down i want to be settled
somewhere
the fireplace going or somebody drew a
fireplace and i pinned it up
and i want uh
i want that music
i want the mute i don't care if the
house burns down
as long as i can hear a peaceful tune
i don't care if we never see the cat
again i don't care
i just want to relax
and hear a peaceful christmas tune
and have me a little cookie
the cookies i like the ones that moms
make
with just the sugar on them or the ones
that have the star in them
uh and they're star-shaped you know mom
gets the cutter
puts it in there
and the stocking when moms make the
stocking one that those burn for some
reason
the back of those always burn up
but then mitch is good you know i like
them
i like cookies that are burnt
i like a burnt cookie because you got
somebody to complain at
i like a cookie that comes with a reason
for me to [__] at the end of it
you know hey
the [__]
and you still
oh i'll have four more
i'll have four more of them burnt
[__] but
you're gonna hear about it
yeah i just want to wish you a merry
christmas and a happy holidays and
happy kwanzaa if you do that happy
ramadan
if you do that happy damn
leap year whatever you celebrate
whatever you celebrate i'm gonna wish
you it
you know happy uh
happy birthday if your birthday's on
christmas man you're [__]
but happy birthday to you nobody cares
but you do
and that's gotta be hectic but
oh well you [__]
um
yeah can you imagine having a birthday
on christmas you walk out with a
birthday cake
and everybody's like
we don't [__] care
could you imagine that people you're
like hey come over here while i blow out
the candles
and people were like blow out my nuts
son
santa's here
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one